[Music]
you think about this the dumbest premise
effort it really is I bought some cheap
books and I'm gonna show them to you I
bought the heaviest books I could find
these are very interesting coffee table
arrived for example this one I find it
fascinating its movie stars with their
eyes moved closer together yeah look
it's even got more of them on the back
Brad Pitt they're just let's see--let's
worried about something
he just looks kind of like Keith Urban
yeah he does everything sorry Keith
Urban okay no no we're not watching
famous this one is a coffee table book
that just didn't so I don't know why
it's called famous scenes from Star Wars
presented by JC Penney and this this is
just get in there oh I love what they're
wearing I really do that that's all I've
never had more respect for Darth Vader
it's crazy the jean-georges cost more
than the khaki and then look look at
this picture on the back I got to show
this this completely
pretty sure that's singing Slave Leia
the same no it really isn't but
affordable very affordable everyone's
talking about tan mom sure is days I
love her yeah everyone something well
here's a book coffee table book called
tan mom baked goods there there she is
as a brownie and then over here she is
of course chocolate truffle chocolate
truffle and then I think she's also is
that rye bread you company company
company
okay there you go okay you're all just
jealous okay this is a book I'm not
surprised this one didn't sell well oh
really what I'm really not in okay do I
show it they can't wait to see it Conan
I'm gonna stay right here thanks pal
it's called guys who often get mistaken
for mobile boy get Stanley Tucci there
you see why and then you can see on the
back you've got James Carville yeah yeah
and you've got professor honeydew and
then of course our own mark
[Applause]
this is nice this is kind of a book that
takes a look a nice vintage look the way
things used to be those are down
nostalgia this was called old-timey gas
prices oh boy
thank you God barely remember that
beautiful yet really Wow
those were the days were the days this
I'm this one I'm keeping I love this one
it's called extremely suggestive animal
photos animal photos there's a lot of
really yeah and then look back here
[Applause]
what's going on down there
oh boy what Andy somebody's getting
Bruno I was gonna let that one go oh not
me
no wow this one isn't very not much in
this book yet so thin very thin it's
calling there's a reason why it's things
Chris Christie won't eat yeah it's
really nice this is where he draws the
line yeah
no celery or Jupiter and then I think
this is my favorite I got this one cuz I
love it yeah well you know people talk
about is there life on other plate
do aliens visit this planet do they
leave us signs well they do it's called
dirty crop circle boy dirty top surface
right there
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
oh wait a minute hey hey forgot I was
told before the show I can't show the
ones on the chef's house was like oh you
can show the ones on the back oh dear
ya think it's too dirty no man alright
the extra-terrestrial children watch it